you do
this
King Charles makes his debut as the new
reigning monarch following the death of
his mother Queen Elizabeth Charles will
indeed be known as King Charles III he
could have chosen to take a different
name as king he has chosen King Charles
III that's Charles and his wife who's
also got a title change Queen Camilla
taking in all the flowers and tributes
outside Buckingham Palace at one point
he greets the crowd and shakes several
hands and get this Charles stops briefly
in front of a woman who asked if she
could kiss him and well he accepted
foreign
[Music]
the King has officially declared a royal
morning period following Queen
Elizabeth's death I think the pictures
that we saw are of family members
arriving at Balmoral really said it all
this is a family
um in mourning now and um of course the
queen was a mother a grandmother and a
great grandmother Buckingham Palace
shared an official release from his
majesty noting that the period of Royal
morning starts now until seven days
after the Queen's funeral as for who
must observe the royal family Royal
household staff and Royal
Representatives on official duties as
well as troops committed to ceremonial
duties
foreign
doesn't have a date yet but as far as
king Charles's coronation goes that's
expected to happen sooner rather than
later at present there is no official
confirmation of the timeline of
Charles's coronation but all the sources
who I have spoken to including from my
book the new Royals suggests that
Charles will have a coronation far
sooner than his mother's coronation
there was a full year between the death
of King George VI and the coronation of
Queen Elizabeth and this is going to be
a much shorter time period Prince of
Wales has been our longest serving
Prince of Wales the longest King in
waiting and I expect that his coronation
will be certainly in a matter of months
rather than a year
foreign